[Musique]
c'est en langue 1764 que d'abate apparu
sur nos terres et l'officiel sous ses
assauts le pays de gévaudan s'enfonçait
peu à peu dans les ténèbres
et l'on commencé à penser que nulle
mortels n'en viendra jamais à bout
voici au chevalier grégoire de consac
parle-t-on beaucoup de la pète à paris
on en fait même des chansons alors qu'on
devrait dire des prières on m'a chargé
d'en faire le portrait de la naturaliser
sitôt après la chasse sans maison était
allongé ses dents des couteaux
ct kwh alors des gens aux 100 morts
j'entends l'entrée sur scène les
personnages c'est mon frère
marianne de ma jeunesse tribaux partie
du pays sont cassé les dents vous êtes
un libertin tu t'es encore
on n'est pas libertin quand on aime vous
aimez
alou enragé attaquera n'importe qui
aucun animal à des crocs de fer sur vous
vous moquez constitué de la bête elle va
continuer à tenir
cette fois nous leurrons
il
[Applaudissements]
n'en parlons plus jamais du gévaudan
n'est ce pas
[Musique]
chiche